hey thanks everyone for coming out my
name is Andrew as my colleague I'm
critics of augie and as I mentioned we
work out wayfair.com up in Boston and
there are some things that I think are
important to understand about Wayfarer
in the context of this presentation so
we're an online destination for all
things home so ecommerce site for
furniture and home goods mostly we have
a lot of products over 7 million 7,000
plus suppliers to have a very large data
set we've been around since 2002 so the
weight name wayfair is actually a little
newer we kind of rebranded a few years
ago but we've been around for a while
and our code base has been around for a
while we have several large websites
wayfair.com being the main one but they
all run on the shared code base so the
most part all our products share the
same code and that code is a PHP
back-end custom-built ecommerce platform
in MVC platform millions lines of code
thousands of JavaScript modules so it's
an extensive code base right performance
matters right I know it's obviously not
probably all if you know it but I'm just
gonna say it anyway so a
high-performance app can lead to a
better customer experience that in turn
probably leads to better revenue right
and that's kind of important so in order
to get this high performance we are kind
of doing some things on the server side
keys yeah so we have abused mustache in
PHP on the server side and we're
actually rendering this stuff with a C++
extension and that's like super fast we
also lazy load most of our non-critical
images like stop below the fold be these
load data and also like some j/s modules
for example if you have a modal that you
want to show and until you actually show
it we don't load the j/s for it right so
we also do some intelligent bundling on
the JavaScript side for cash
optimizations yeah so we're doing a lot
of things right in terms performance but
there was always room for improvement
and as our pages became more and more
interactive we realized that the area
where we can improve the most of the
client side so we were using backbone
on the client and some backbone works
with jquery out of box to do all your
rendering and so this is sort of a
standard render method and backbone you
implement your own render methods so in
this method basically just taking the
element for a review using the jquery
object for that that's been pre-selected
for us and we're using jquery to HTML to
pass in our new string for our HTML
that's acquired by using our template
function that we free compiled calling
render on it and passing in our data and
this was fine but they're a couple of
problems with it one being we tend to
over render so maybe only part of our
view changes maybe we're only changing a
class name or a text node but what we're
doing here in sort of a naive render
method is work rerun during everything
we read running that view no matter what
changed in fact we're rerunning that
view even if nothing changed so even if
nothing changed on our view maybe if
we're calling render whenever our data
model changes which is a common pattern
and now we're rerender even we don't
need to we're hitting the Damas we don't
have to and that became problematic oh
the other end of this the kind of
compensate for this is well devs would
just use kind of precise Dom
manipulations so we might take our our
jQuery object here and just call add
class on it so that's fine it's a fast a
problem is that this does not scale it's
not maintainable as an architecture we
started realizing that parts of our code
base ended up being filled with these
direct Dom manipulations and it was very
hard to reason about the state of our
application at any one time I'm in
addition to that you know devs have to
think about kind of low level
performance you know this would always
come up in a code review and you guys
all work with JavaScript probably every
day so maybe you're familiar with this
you know that jQuery empty is actually a
lot faster than passing in an empty
string to jquery HTML but that's not
something that all our full stack devs
were aware of and it's not something
they should have to be aware of and so
you know you'd end up with all these
little petty comments and code reviews
like this is faster than this this is
faster than this and that just we wanted
a better abstraction for that we didn't
want to have to have devs have to worry
about this sort of low level down
performance when they're writing their
code so what do we do now yeah that was
a good question and that was a question
that kind of face
our team how can we improve the
client-side performance that we have
within our current stack and you know i
think the the interesting solution was
let's just rewrite everything there are
some really great libraries out there
right we we started looking around and
we could have rear end to ember because
members really cool now and it has
glimmer so it's kind of fast and there's
really great community there were some
cool things going on with angular and we
could have decided you know we're going
to rewrite to angular 2 and we'll do
that this summer and it'll be it'll be a
project but at the end of the day we'll
have this this cool angular app for
everything to be honest what excited us
the most was react so we looked at react
and we're like this is great if I were
starting a side project like this is
exactly what I would use why don't we
just rewrite everything to react and I
think if the dev it's really exciting to
like look at this and go you know
imagine a greenfield project or we have
a legacy co-pay let's just delete
everything and rewrite it again but this
thing like the worst mistake that you
can make is actually writing entire
thing they even Joe is polski agrees
with me so I it's problematic and that's
disappointing um I think it's devs we
like want to take kind of new and shiny
yeah libraries and just use them and so
we're sort of told we can't at that's
that's disappointing rewrites
unexpensive i mean like it did it so
much time like you have to actually stop
all future development you can't really
like you know like your project does not
progress so and most of the times you
actually never get done with it because
it because of all these problems right
and without actual tests like you're
going to break a lot of stuff right yeah
so the alternative is working with
legacy code which is is not really fun
it's it's an idea when I look at it
that's that isn't that attractive
particularly for a lot of these
characteristics of legacy code bases so
legacy code bases mean you need to work
in the existing tech stack and those
might be text acts that grew organically
over a lot of years like ours where that
you know they're a little bit quirky
there are parts of it that you know if I
were to start again today maybe I
wouldn't do it that way there certainly
were reasons that that that happened
whether they be a historical or whether
they be you know unique to the problem
space that we are solving
it means that you have to use old
frameworks and libraries and this
doesn't mean bad frameworks or libraries
it just means things that are older in
some spaces this is good but it also
means that you know there might be a
community around or there might not they
might have the newest technology or they
might not but you have a lot of code
existing already in these environments
and means you have to work with
technical debt all applications have
technical debt and so when you have to
dive into your legacy code it means you
have to look at that and kind of face
that head-on and none of this is
attractive i think to to front end dev
but i think one of the most important
things about legacy code base is that it
actually works right i mean this is this
is amazing code by by Hendrick who's the
creator of ampersand I really like it
like he says that you don't really have
to burn down your whole house if you
want to remodel the kitchen right so I
mean I think that's a great analogy to
software development and I really like
my living room I really like the
bathroom and I I mean I really like all
the other rooms in my house right so so
so we have a lot of good things that are
going for us right so we also have views
shared templates so we actually have
masters champion sort of shared on the
server side and the client side so we
like that part we we have a very fast
server side rendering because we use
like a c++ extension for mustache on PHP
we also have a lot of existing backbone
components so for example like you know
Garrison's more to the syndics lag so we
don't want to get rid of those so we
really like all of that stuff but there
are things that we liked that were out
there already there were things that
were like we like better in libraries
that had been built in the last few
years that really sources of innovation
and they're inspiring for us so as our
application again became more more
interactive fast client side rendering
was really attractive and we looked at
libraries out there that were a lot
better than what we were doing right now
one of the big piece of this was using
virtual Dom this idea that we could do a
deafening ever DOM and memory not
actually have to hit it on until we need
to and be able to batch and do precise
Dom updates with an abstraction that was
a
was a lot easier to deal with we liked
this idea that we didn't have to do Dom
manipulation with a lot of these new
frameworks we really didn't want our
devs having to work with the Dom
directly it was not a scalable
architecture it was not maintainable and
it ended up with a lot of the messes and
the bugs that had to work with and we
ended up having to like search down
these obscure bugs like you see
something change on the page but you
don't know what changed it may be the
dom break point is helpful maybe it
isn't and so that can be a particularly
challenging so what do we do it all
again it seems to be a recurring
question sure it was so we looked at
what we had we looked at what was out
there and we're kind of faced with a
dilemma it really wasn't feasible to
rewrite everything we had but it wasn't
feasible to keep going down the path
that we were going and so we decided to
kind of take some advice from that idea
of modularity to take this idea that we
can look at the individual pieces of our
application the ones that we like the
ones that we wanted to swap out and do
that on a library by library basis and
there are a lot of really interesting
libraries out there that we could do
that with and so we ended up looking for
libraries that would take all these
pieces that we wanted so the first thing
that we did was look for a better way to
precompiler mustache templates there's
this library out of the Guardian called
reactive and r actives kind of made for
it for as a client-side framework and it
was cool we weren't as interested in
some of the API pieces in the front and
side of it but we realize is that we
could pull out the compiler that they
were using for mustache templates and
use that on our server when we pre
compile our templates to compile them to
objects rather than strings so we did
that we swapped out our compiler on the
server side then we went to this idea of
virtual Dom there's this library called
mercury it's sort of a smaller library
have some of the same ideas of using
virtual Dom but it decouples its virtual
Dom library has its own module which was
cool so we could actually pull this
library again we really weren't as
interested in the API on Mercury it
didn't have the mustache templates that
we wanted for for writing our markup but
it didn't have this
core functionality for dipping and
patching that we needed on the client
side and so we use that along with our
active precompile templates to do our
differing on the plan and then we use
backbone which we are already using
across our code base to do our normal
event finding and handle our data layer
we added a few features into this so we
actually had an event global event
handler similar to to react the handle
virtual events so bind all events in one
place as opposed to binding them all
around our document and delegating from
there we wrote an integration library to
pull this all together we call that
library at tungsten we open source it a
couple months ago so that was kind of
exciting and it's certainly not
something that will fit into you know
everyone's texts at but it made a lot of
sense for us it made a lot of sense for
us because at its core it has this idea
of modularity that it wants to be able
to have the ability to swap out
different pieces so for example we're
using the virtual Dom library from the
mercury project but we have an adapter
so that we can swap in any virtual Dom
library that we want and we benchmarked
it with different implementations in the
past and that's something that we can do
if you know if something comes down the
line a few years from now and we want to
pull in it uses backbone in our code
base but that's set a separate layer so
we're not where'd you where D couple
from backbone itself and we have
implementations and other form in
frameworks as well so that's certainly
something as we look like how we want to
handle our data on the client side and
maybe how we want to use an API for
building out our views we can change
that down the line without replacing the
whole thing and so what we're able to do
is is write something that really worked
for us and work within our tech stack
and I think at the start of it we're
sort of afraid of writing something new
you know there's the not invented here
syndrome right that you know we need
need to just write everything in house
and that's very that's very true a lot
of places i'm sure ourselves included to
some extent we write a lot of stuff
in-house and maybe we could use
externally I'm that being said I think
there's there's kind of the opposite end
of that there are teams that don't want
to write anything because they're afraid
that you know they couldn't do it as
well as as anything else that out there
and maybe they couldn't but you all have
like unique problems a lot of us are
facing very interesting
for us it was that we're not a single
page app we weren't going to be there a
lot of reasons that we couldn't switch
to a single page app SEO just being one
of them and that's certainly changing
but even that aside I think there's
something to be said for delivering a
page that's a fully render to our user a
page that progressively falls back and
works with our JavaScript which is
something that was very important to us
as well so all of these kind of features
made us a little bit more unique I think
then some of your normal single page
applications there's this also this idea
that we discovered of using existing
infrastructure and this is a picture of
barbed wire fence and I read this really
cool story a few months ago and it's
that at the early part of the 20th
century as telephone was sort of making
its way across the United States it was
really expensive tool a new wires
especially in parts of the country that
were vast and there were there were
large distances between these houses and
so in the Great Plains in the American
West we had whole swathes of land that
just wasn't affordable to lay new
telephone wires the telephone companies
just weren't interested in it because it
was just way too expensive and so what
farmers did in a very I think in a way
that's similar to you how hackers
approach problems is they looked at what
they had already they had a lot of these
bribed wire fences that actually join
entire farm so that they could separate
land and that's how they kept animals
from roaming between farms and they
realized that you know the
infrastructure was already there they
could leverage those barbed wires to
actually transmit telephone signals
across large areas of land without
having to build anything new and so
that's what they did these groups of
farmers just came together and they
started implementing a telephone
infrastructure through their existing
barbed wire fences and this was really
interesting to me because I looked at
this and I said you know it's not
perfect like maybe the signal was a
little bit worse maybe they had to
maintain it a little bit more but at the
end of the day they had a telephone
service that they just weren't going to
get otherwise and sure it would have
been great if they could have gotten new
new telephone poles and in strong up new
brand new copper across the whole
but that wasn't going to happen for
years and it wasn't affordable and it
was far too expensive and that sounded
really familiar so you know what we were
able to do is take the existing
infrastructure that we had with its good
parts and with its bad parts and write
something new that gave us the features
that we wanted so that's something and
so I'm just going to show some demos
here how many of you have seen the DB
monster demo implementation all right so
a few of you I'm just going to pull one
up here so this is DB monster and
angular and Ryan Florence demoed this at
recomp this year and it's just a really
basic application that updates this set
of this table sort of simulate the idea
of a database monitoring question
monitoring out and so we have data
that's changing very quickly and we have
hundreds of rows which for some
applications might be the case so if you
have very you have a lot of database
clusters that you might eat them on or
anything unique monitor now you
certainly have applications that are
updating the stuff so we have
implementations in all different
libraries and the interesting thing
about this is that we're able to see how
quickly we're able to update a table
with 200 rose actually says 100 bits
200s master and slave for each row and
then we can see how slow it is so the
slower ones will drop frames because
JavaScript won't be able to handle the
updates and the browser will will start
dropping frames so you'll kind of see
the drink so this is angular 1.3 which I
think was several months ago but so
let's see we have we have a little bit
of genk as I scroll I don't know how oh
well it shows up on the projector and
pull up the console and I have a
function called a run timer so run timer
will run over five seconds and it'll see
how many times you can run render in a
second over a course of five little
sample
okay so you get 4.4 renders per second
so that that's you know pretty good but
it definitely is janky here all right
now we have amber one now and this is a
little problematic because it tends to
cross the browser tab sometimes all
right so we get occasional updates all
right so down to about one render a
second so that's that's a little slow
and of course these are synthetic
benchmarks but I think they're useful to
see in this case how fast we can we can
update or down so when I informed stem
of this it was all about reactor so this
is react we run Dover five seconds able
to get 10 run in a second that's pretty
fast it's really smooth if I scroll down
here a very little drink all right so
ember influence the glimmer engine
recently take their own approach to
updating the DOM and just as fast as
react now so that was really exciting at
amber comp this year so we get 900
second so just about at react speech so
we looked at all this this was sort of
what we looked at before we wrote
tungsten we're like really want to be
this fast renew we can do it with our
current infrastructure but you know as
we realize that we couldn't rewrite
everything we knew we probably wouldn't
get to those speeds and we wanted to
sort of be in the same ballpark that was
kind of the goal so let's see what we
can get understand Jenkins want too bad
let's see what we get for renders
alright so I'm ten or two seconds so
pretty pretty close to mboro glimmer and
react yeah thank you yeah we were really
happy with it and you know we looked at
this in at the end of the day if you
know a few renders more more or less per
second wasn't really a game changer but
it was is cool to be there and kind of
be in that space and realize that we
could do it you know taking our existing
our existing infrastructure I have this
last library that I want a demo in this
is just really lightweight library
called paper clip and it does dipping a
little bit different way it's really
fast so what's interesting about this is
we looked around we realized there's
still more work that we can do there's
still places that we can improve there
are still optimizations that we can make
in terms of updating parts to our page
or doing different faster or
conditionally doing different based on
our changing data the interesting thing
is that we can do this ourselves now as
opposed to having to rely on a library
to do that for us we can start to find
places in our own code in our own
implementations and see where it's
useful to make it faster where it might
give us the most benefit so if I pull up
this library which we've we've been
looking at it that's really fast and
this is actually going to be quite
fascinated implementations yeah 30
wonders say so the point being you know
there's more work to do and it's nice to
be able to do that in our existing
infrastructure and make progress in a
way that makes sense for for our use
cases and for our customers and yeah
we'd love to hear your feedback on
tungsten I have stickers because
apparently you've made it like as a
library you get your own stickers so uh
all right thank you
you